[Music]
accepted now i'm black great
it was a trick engineered by hicaro
okay he actually takes on f6 here
yeah this line
okay let's play with magnus plays b
which is b5 and queen a5 knight b6
and h5
i think i just go here and ignore
to take
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like i did something wrong here i
thought this was theory before
not too concerned about a trade i feel
like i'll have counterplay
[Music]
i'm not too impressed with this i guess
i can take work
on that
and i kind of have to
okay one i have to take
i kind of walked into c4 but
gnarly position
he never has c4 because then i take
there's a time i think i can start
by playing g6 there's no rush on 1969
just improve my position first
from the knight to six nights
i definitely want to take that now let's
get the knight there
[Music]
do i want to go five
i don't see a need to do that
immediately
he's obviously okay let's play a fight
now
blended h5 that's not good
it should be six next
now i wanna take
almost played 93 there
[Music]
maybe let's go g5
[Music]
oh and i blundered your but i have this
[Music]
[Music]
i got to be very very careful here
[Music]
[Music]
so
okay finally
i don't know who was playing for a win
there
yeah i think he was trying to flag me in
the end
but i had a little too much time
okay this stuff again
[Music]
oh
keep walking into h4 i keep forgetting
that's a move i don't know why
i don't like that now i have to go g4
and he always goes for the same
structure
every game
for the subs okay takes of the epony
used to do that more often
i feel like this is bad
oh he's got this
i forgot about that as well
okay so i guess it's not bad
the other hand
bishop is going to be bad at the end
he's gonna have a bad bishop although he
has a square
i don't know
probably bad move
takes
setting up some cheap tricks
i don't know where this is going to go
yeah that's an annoying move
yeah that's actually really really bad
for me because if i move my rookies
rookie five
this also potentially hangs
very bold to allow d5 but i guess he
wants to take
queen b65
okay fine
okay again d5 exists
this time d5 is quite a bit more
appealing
let's risk it
oh he wants c5
another trick
that was his idea of course
i've seen that
now i got my traps
[Music]
[Music]
consecutive wonders
[Music]
one specialty
wow he rarely plays the fiance
d3 isn't correct
wow it's like knight b1 or something
maybe queen f6 is stronger i feel like
maybe queen f6 now
this is a big trouble for white i think
i think i should have gone queen f6 on
the previous move
i don't know it's hard to say
okay knight takes f2 is interesting king
takes up two
okay wait a minute
if i take it takes
i think i'm winning a piece
i think i take here and then take the
knight
okay let's not mess this this is not so
easy he's got some pawns
okay definitely we want to go here
okay once shouldn't have allowed that
i guess i have
c4 maybe in c3
do
yeah i've managed to make this very
complicated
somehow
i can't play rook seat i mean it's it's
unreal
how he does this
and he's going to go a3 you mean he's
just probably better this way
so
probably i should do it here
okay he can't go e6 which is helpful i
want to take him to rookie 8.
i don't even know where i went wrong
[Music]
[Music]
surprise to bishop e6
now i want to take and go rook fba
okay wait
i gotta move
oh bishop f7 oh no
okay
way too slow
and now i blundered or did it
oh my god how did i manage
god
why do i always get nervous like that
okay i'm gonna give me a draw
probably should have won that at the end
if i didn't blend with the piece
although it's not easy
yeah let's buy a belgrade
okay it was not so easy to flag me there
very sloppy opening flight by him but
not punishing it of course
thanks uh
yeah i mean at the end i was already
winning i just avoided blundering the
piece
i also wanted the rope there what we
didn't explain
your hands start to shake
oh i had knight takes d6
i'm just saying opportunities left and
right
i guess enjoy
just come on that takes d6 here
[Music]
to
[Music]
yeah definitely if he hits 3200 he's
definitely gonna stop
okay i need to turn my phone off
i hear one more buzz
[Music]
[Music]
probably what he's selling here but i
don't explain it
i guess a 5 would be a good move to
insert just in general
maybe he can get away with taking i
don't think so though
[Music]
i don't know about this but it's
interesting
[Music]
i was gonna sack the exchange but now i
realize it doesn't work so maybe i can
take
or am i blundering some
garbage here
if he checks me and takes i have bishop
e5 queen c2 bishop takes f6 rook fake
d6 yeah
[Music]
i don't know
very hard to say what's going on here
this sacrifice is also on the on on the
on deck here
okay so he allows it
and this has to be winning for me
there's no question
maybe not
rook f6 gf queen f6 what does he want
there
i don't know
i don't see i don't see how he defends
all right whatever
i can't even i can't get low on time
i'm just gonna move
i'm gonna trust that it's winning
okay if he goes rick d7
i don't know what i'm gonna do
takes it wow okay
i guess i have to take
really riley
really riley
check okay we could just take pawns but
i don't want to
i want to check him
d6
very careful here
let's check him again now let's go to d6
okay he's threatening a draw
amazingly
is there is there nothing that i can do
to stop this draw idea
i think there might be
okay let's try that
[Music]
let's go
very precise play in the end by me i
think
okay we've had this a million times
wait no it should be seven he's gonna
why am i forgetting all of a sudden
whoa data with the 20. oh man look who's
here my teammate from twitch rivals
thank you daddo
the absolute hero from twitch rivals i
should say
dm girl
okay
we take those thank you for the 20
gifted my friend
yeah definitely not he's going for speed
here over opening accuracy
okay let's go rook c8 get the rook in
oh i allowed
shouldn't have done that either
now i forgot he's threatening this
completely
so now we have to be careful this queen
b6 he's got a fork
completely unnecessary to allow that i
guess if he takes i could go knight
before
okay so i could
hypothetically trade everything
i have the
i could also go something like here and
then maybe bishop a7 to hit the pawn
okay let's go queen g5 hit the okay wait
queen g5 takes takes knight f7 is
problematic potentially
oh is it
we calculate further knight f7
king f yeah it is
okay so let's trade a pair
and let's go with the
plan of bishop a7
[Music]
[Music]
f5 isn't is an interesting mode but it
is weakening
[Music]
man that was a bad move of h6 i mean i'm
just gonna make some looks here
probably not worth it okay this was my
idea
wait now if he takes it i have bishop
takes d4 i think for the bits
wait a minute and f4 bishop f4 bishop d4
and bishop g2 i have something insane
like that
knight for queen f4 bishop d4
king h1
ah this doesn't work
oh man okay i gotta move
let's just move back
okay let's move much faster than i've
moved
very good shape here but fast
oh one of the piece nice this is what
happens when you get too long
okay seven is terrible i mean at that
point i'm already under some pressure
but queen b8 and i'm fine
[Music]
i'm going to make a draw
i want to let it have oh he's going for
it okay
against the cars berlin i've decided
that making draws is probably the best
option
okay wait what is this
because it puts the psychological
pressure on him because he obviously
doesn't want to draw
this is terrible for black i gotta win
this game
what is this
i don't know i guess i don't really want
to take on facade
what am i doing now
i should have taken up that's for sure
i mean icaru himself has taken that draw
many times so to his credit he doesn't
really criticize me for it
i've never heard him like
object too much to it
he takes d6 or q1 he had bishop e6 i
don't think it was that simple
what's up jose welcome to charlotte
yeah of course oh sorry i will vip him
immediately
sorry that you weren't vip yet
now jose is in the vip
i actually blundered the stroke
but i think that's still fine because i
have knight f6 and there's got to be
something there
knowing hikaru is probably going to take
on gifting to jose
okay he actually whoa
where's the knockout there let's not do
anything panicky
let's go like this
he wants knight f5
let's just go like this
knight f5 i'll take it and i'll play
that position
i still have this knight on f6 it's a
shame to part ways of the bishop
let's hit him here
i could also have taken a gun a6 but i
go for the domination instead
okay which rook do we want to go to d1
probably this one
i guess he'll take on b2 and i'll have
nothing
i don't know
rick takes d392 maybe king h1
out of there
and they want to play passively here
what else do i have
where's the wind
are you yay
i don't see it
my landline do this
great
see the strategy works
this line i think d5 is good here
buy what he's selling here let's go here
let's go a5 b6 and bishop a6 try this
for this idea
i'm gonna
toss the pawn and go bishop a6 try to
play for a win here
castle's long which makes a lot of sense
bishop c5 queen g5
you could also go queen e7 maybe this
was hasty
okay let's go queen e7
g5 anyway
okay so he allows i don't know i can't
take his mcqueen hangs in the end
and if i go h6 with the idea
this probably is the strongest though
because now i'm threatening bishop takes
c3
also a4 was interesting
okay so let's go
kick the queen away let's see where it
goes
i'll make a decision accordingly
so i have to watch for this idea
a little worried about putting the king
in the line of fire oh yeah
exactly like that but i don't see a
threat so i think
ah bishop g5 maybe
between e6
all right let's move back
whoa our trey's all thank you for the
gifts appreciate you
okay rook d8g5 really riley
let's go ahead
gotta do something now because he's
about to check me at me
i'm a little worried the g5 is just
winning he takes it gonna go bishop c4
but i don't think i'm fast enough
unfortunately this vienna is so annoying
i haven't i have a desperation idea
let's see if this
works oh he's got rookie for
completely blind
i thought he had to play knight e4
yeah he just shuts down the counterpoint
[Music]
that was a bad game
i was never even never really in it
nike for example
this line okay i think i've been playing
bishop e3 successfully
oh wait no the move is bishop c4
bishop p3 was ridiculous
okay we can't i can't lose this one like
that let's go knight two three
i have to hold this hold this hole to
draw here
somehow in bad shape
okay this is not so bad i have some
chances now
holy smokes
now i'm very i'm honored that this is
the gm the stream where the gm is hung
out hang out
that should be my
my like slogan
the latest
raging elitist that i am
all right
let's go
okay he takes up the pawn there has to
be something here there's just no way
you can get away with this kind of
loosey goosey flap it should d4 bishop
c5
7 maybe there no
that doesn't work bishop a2 is
interesting
maybe maybe patience is a virtue here
but no that doesn't work either
okay let's try this
if only i had bishop a2 and i feel like
maybe i'm overestimating this in the
first place
i felt like these ideas i mean there's
so many tactics here
okay queen h6
is interesting then he's got some
nitrogen for monkey business
i take c4 bishop hd4
yeah
he's probably going to move the knight
somewhere if i go here but knight h5
something
and i'm lost there as well
what about this move
okay
so solid
if only i should probably get h3 and as
soon as possible
probably should keep pieces on the board
what if i take
like there's a trap here
no it just goes back and now i'm in good
shape
and i shouldn't have allowed her
here
it's a long time again
so slow
okay let's try to trade it you know wait
till it comes
and i hold it
is
that's unfortunate
that's just unfortunate i mean there's
just unlucky
one tempo and if one temp i would have
been winning
but there was nothing i could have done
i mean that pawn end game was lost i
guess
he figures out knight b2 which is 92 she
didn't even know
but figures it out
completely equal
i have to play much faster i blended the
pawn
ah but then i had her a6 good
or maybe not equal maybe i'm just worse
here in these types of positions
yeah i should have gone knight d7 first
because against cicar i just can't get
these types of positions
as a general rule
these like
positional end games are
essentially unplayable but let's see b6
let's try to trick him
ah this should be four
i missed that as well
h5 maybe
uh but then he's got rook c7 but if rick
d7 he's got rook d1
in that case i should probably force him
to close down the seat belt for
temporarily
okay now let's go h5 we have to activate
our bishop
this is essential
[Music]
then he's going to go h3 and f3
did i just walk into knight c4
[Music]
yes i did
so
another ridiculous line rook c39 g4 rook
c2 king d3
and how is this possible
there's nothing
although maybe
he checks me first
[Music]
yeah i'm completely lost
oh he's got
[Music]
bishop gotta start winning
let's go early d5
again he's simply much worse out of the
opening
as is normally the case
this just
i shouldn't lose this
it's just good for me
or maybe not so good i don't know
what's going this
yeah this is maybe two garage
[Music]
it goes like that
probably shouldn't have allowed that
although now i'm going to go
thank you chris
let's go
if he goes b5 i can go b4 and then his
b-pawn is weak
okay so if i take it he goes back to d
that's his idea
if i go before
yeah let's go before i don't trust this
shouldn't be worse here because now i'm
threatening potentially b5
i think he made a mistake
okay if i lose this
i mean he will obviously run because
he'll be 3200 okay not b5 yet because
he's got some miraculously got knight a7
because in that case let's just walk the
king in
and he stops me right now
i move my rook he goes knight a7 he's
much better
so in a sense i'm totally paralyzed
and now i think
b5 is probably on deck here
[Music]
he goes b5 himself now
okay we come back
i'm not sure what to do but again i'm
too slow
for active counter play
my blunder95
yeah
[Music]
yes drag me into these
end games
yeah not good
okay i think he's probably gonna end
here
this was this is the game that pissed me
off
because that was just much better
oh knight takes g6 is winning on the
spot
yeah blunder this easy tactic
yeah i mean these missing these chances
completely inexcusable
well
i mean
this guy accepted at the same time as
brandon
okay let's play a few with brandon and
then uh couple with chaotic
[Music]